...
-Corine Pelluchon,
vous êtes philosophe
et vous vous êtes vite intéressée
aux questions de bioéthique,
d'écologie, en lien avec
la philosophie politique.
Vous êtes très engagée
dans la cause animale,
vous êtes végane,
vous n'aimez pas qu'on le dise,
ou en tout cas,
qu'on vous y réduise,
mais sans pour autant rejeter
l'héritage de la modernité
et notamment des Lumières,
ce qui est pourtant
la pente naturelle
de ceux qu'on appelle
les abolitionnistes.
Nous traversons
une crise majeure
climatique,
mais aussi civilisationnelle.
Or, précisément,
il est communément admis
que la crise est en grande partie
le résultat de cette modernité.
Alors, comment concilier
les Lumières
et ce que vous,
vous appelez
"l'âge du vivant" ?
Qu'est-ce qu'on garde des Lumières,
qu'est-ce qu'on jette ?
-D'abord,
on peut définir les Lumières,
qui désignent moins
un continent ou une époque
qu'une manière
de regarder le présent
de façon critique, en identifiant
ses défis et les tâches
permettant de renouer le lien
entre la théorie et la pratique.
Et en ce sens,
les Lumières désignent toujours
un processus inachevé
à reprendre à chaque époque.
Mais il y a quand même
un socle de principes
qui définissent les Lumières
contre leurs ennemis
de toujours,
les Anti-Lumières.
Ce socle de principes,
pour être claire ou simple,
il se caractérise
par l'autonomie,
l'idée qu'on peut
prendre en main son destin.
Le deuxième principe,
c'est l'égalité,
donc un ordre
social et politique
fondé sur l'égalité
des êtres humains.
Le troisième,
c'est l'unité du genre humain,
qui s'est traduit entre autres
par les droits de l'homme.
Et la quatrième idée
ou le quatrième principe,
c'est la rationalité,
la raison
comme outil majeur
pour s'émanciper.
Et contre cela s'opposent
les Anti-Lumières,
qui veulent asseoir un ordre
sur des hiérarchies,
sur la théologie, la religion,
sur un essentialisme,
donc une différence biologique
entre les humains qui justifierait
un assujettissement
des uns par les autres,
et les Anti-Lumières
se caractérisent aussi
par une haine de la raison,
qui est une arme de guerre
contre ce projet d'émancipation.
Et moi, je garde ces principes,
je pense qu'ils sont
très importants,
notamment aujourd'hui,
parce que les Anti-Lumières
se manifestent un peu partout
par le retour des nationalismes,
par les politiques de puissances,
d'empires, de guerres, etc.,
mais je crois, effectivement,
que pour maintenir ces quatre
principes et l'esprit des Lumières
et peut-être les prolonger,
puisqu'elles sont
un héritage inachevé,
il faut, paradoxalement,
critiquer leurs fondements,
en particulier le dualisme
nature/culture,
cette séparation radicale
de l'humain
avec la nature
et les autres vivants,
et donc arracher, comme on le ferait
d'une écharde dans la chair,
l'anthropocentrisme,
qui est un point de vue étroit
consistant à considérer
que l'humain est au centre
et que les autres êtres
n'ont de valeur qu'instrumentale.
-Je vais vous proposer d'écouter
une archive de 1972
de Lévi-Strauss.
-Nous savons bien, d'une côté,
que la culture,
l'ensemble des croyances,
des institutions,
des pratiques que les hommes mettent
en oeuvre dans leur vie sociale,
que tout cela est une partie
de la nature
et en même temps,
nous avons intérêt,
au point de vue opérationnel,
je dirais presque,
à faire comme si c'était un règne,
un domaine complètement séparé.
Et j'imagine que vous êtes
un petit peu
dans la même situation
quand vous êtes confronté
à un problème
comme celui du rapport de la vie
ou de la pensée,
puisque la pensée, c'est évidemment
un phénomène de la vie,
mais que d'un point de vue pratique,
vous avez intérêt à faire
comme si la vie s'expliquait
intégralement par des principes
ou des considérations
tout autres.
-Vous voulez commenter ?
-D'abord, je voudrais dire
mon admiration pour Lévi-Strauss,
qui disait, dans
"Anthropologie structurale deux",
que l'humanisme qu'était le nôtre
était dévergondé
et assis sur un amour-propre.
C'est lié à cette séparation
et les autres vivants,
cette manière d'oublier
que l'humain est aussi
un être vivant,
et cela ouvrait la voie, dit-il,
"à un cycle maudit"
et à l'ensemble
des discriminations
dont le 20e siècle a été témoin.
Alors aujourd'hui,
on repense un peu le rapport
nature/culture, existence/vie.
Il ne s'agit pas de nier
les différences humains/animaux,
il ne s'agit pas de les nier,
mais de comprendre ces lignes
de similitudes et de différences,
comme disait Derrida,
qui également a déconstruit
l'humanisme classique,
et je crois qu'aujourd'hui,
on a la chance,
d'une certaine manière,
de repenser l'humain
sans être obsédé par un propre,
qui se définit de manière élitiste
et réservée à quelques humains.
C'est-à-dire que penser l'humain
seulement comme défini
par la pensée,
même la pensée, laquelle,
celle de l'Occident,
c'est évidemment donner,
prêter le flanc
à une attitude ethnocentriste,
qu'il critiquera,
à une attitude de mépris
à l'égard des autres vivants.
Mais je crois que si on rétablit
un peu les choses
et qu'on adopte "un regard éloigné",
comme il disait,
si on pense avec le voyage,
avec les autres cultures
et aussi les autres vivants,
qu'il y a de multiples manières
de configurer le monde
et de saisir le sens
et que les animaux, par exemple,
aussi, sont des êtres intelligents,
comme disait Montaigne
dans "L'apologie de Raymond Sebon",
"Les Essais",
eh bien, alors, ça enrichit
notre perception des choses,
nous rendant à la fois plus humbles
et plus à l'aise
dans notre
monde. Donc, je crois que...
Lévi-Strauss, c'est, pour moi,
non pas une critique seulement
de l'humanisme passé,
mais l'occasion de penser
un humanisme différent,
de la différence, de l'altérité
et de la diversité.
-Vous tenez une position
un peu similaire,
qui consiste à la fois à être
antispéciste, on peut le dire ?
Peut-être pas jusque-là ?
-Non spéciste.
-Et en même temps, humaniste,
qui sont généralement deux positions
qui s'opposent.
Comment vous les tenez ensemble ?
-Je pense que l'humanisme,
c'est l'idée que pour protéger
la nature et les animaux,
il faut commencer
par repenser
la manière dont l'humain s'est conçu
dans son rapport à la nature,
dans son "être à la nature",
comme disait Michel Serres,
et dans son rapport
au vivant.
-Vous vous êtes beaucoup intéressée
à la cause animale,
autant dans votre vie
que dans votre philosophie.
En quoi cette prise en compte
de l'animal
vient faire bouger les lignes, même
d'un point de vue méthodologique ?
Pourquoi a question animale
vient faire bouger
toutes les lignes
de votre pensée philosophique ?
C'est pas juste un détail
à l'intérieur
ou une région de votre philosophie,
ça a irrigué,
quand même,
une manière de repenser le monde.
-Oui, tout à fait. C'est-à-dire
que d'abord, quand on s'interroge
sur la vulnérabilité,
la passivité du vivant,
il est difficile d'oublier
les animaux qui, comme nous,
sont mortels, vulnérables,
ont faim, froid, et qui,
disait Merleau-Ponty de manière
très belle, dans les années 48,
"qui sont jetés dans un monde
dont ils n'ont pas la clé".
Ca ne tombe pas tout cuit,
si je puis dire.
Il y a une précarité
de l'existence animale,
une inquiétude.
Mais il y a aussi...
C'est vrai que la question animale
a un caractère stratégique,
parce que nous avons longtemps
pensé l'humain,
ou plutôt l'humanité,
en l'opposant à l'animalité,
et ce faisant,
nous définissions les animaux
par ce qu'ils n'avaient pas :
le logos, le langage articulé.
Et c'était une manière
de les simplifier,
de les rater, même, puisqu'on
gommait leur extrême hétérogénéité
et leur singularité.
Ce sont toujours
des êtres individués,
il y a toujours quelqu'un
derrière la fourrure et les plumes.
Et quelqu'un qui nous échappe.
Qui, certes,
a des normes éthologiques,
des besoins de base
liés à son espèce,
mais qui a ses petites préférences.
On a vu tout à l'heure
votre adorable chienne,
qui a ses petites manies
et donc, sa subjectivité,
même si c'est une subjectivité
ou une conscience
non représentationnelle,
elle ne se voit pas vieillir,
elle ne s'interroge pas sur
sa préférence entre Kant ou Hegel,
mais c'est quelqu'un.
Et c'est vrai que,
à mesure que les études
du comportement des animaux,
l'éthologie,
mais aussi la phénoménologie,
enrichissaient notre connaissance
des animaux,
de la complexité
de leur vie psychique,
de leurs besoins, etc.,
les frontières tracées
entre les humains et les animaux
se brouillaient,
sans disparaître complètement,
et tout cela ne conduit pas
à mépriser l'humain
mais au contraire
à réhausser
sa responsabilité qui,
elle, est peut-être
un propre de l'homme,
car les animaux
ne sont pas coupables,
n'ont pas une intentionnalité
comme la nôtre.
En tout cas,
on ne peut pas reprocher,
retomber dans les procès
des animaux
qu'on faisait au Moyen Age,
quand un sanglier faisait des dégâts
dans un jardin,
eh bien, on faisait un procès.
Non, ça n'a pas de sens,
il n'y a pas cette responsabilité-là
chez les animaux.
Donc, il y a bien des différences,
mais c'est vrai
que la question animale,
elle est stratégique parce que,
pour des raisons
de définition de nous-mêmes,
elle est centrale.
Mais surtout, pour moi,
j'ai pris en compte
le fait que les traitements
que nous faisions subir aux animaux,
quasiment dans toutes
les activités,
pour l'élevage, pour la mode,
pour l'expérimentation,
en disait long sur nous-mêmes,
creusait les traits de notre visage.
Le projecteur n'était plus
sur l'objet de la morale
mais sur nous-mêmes, aussi,
et justement,
l'industrialisation
de l'élevage,
le nombre de vies sacrifiées
pour des plaisirs
souvent substituables
et la manière
dont ils sont élevés aujourd'hui,
dans les élevages industriels,
était un coup de projecteur
sur ce que nous sommes devenus
au cours des siècles
et sur ce qu'un modèle
de développement
aberrant et déshumanisant
a fait de nous.
Pour prendre en compte
les animaux dans nos vies
et au coeur du politique,
pour faire que leurs intérêts
comptent malgré tout,
même si ce sont les humains
qui en décident,
il y a toujours cette asymétrie
entre les animaux et nous,
pour arriver à faire cela,
il faut se débarrasser d'habitudes,
remettre en question
bien des pratiques,
par exemple, la corrida,
en ce moment,
il faut aussi innover
pour apprendre à manger
avec moins de viande,
voire sans viande, etc.
Donc c'est, pour moi,
le fer de lance
de ce que j'appelle
un progrès moral
et majeur.
Donc, c'est à la fois
une approche critique,
comme toujours
avec la question animale,
et c'est une approche
constructive,
car elle est aussi,
même dans son pathos,
puisque s'intéresser
aux animaux,
c'est aussi souffrir
de ce qu'on leur fait,
souffrir de la souffrance
des bêtes,
mais elle est aussi porteuse
d'un projet très stimulant.
-Oui.
Je reprends votre terme
de "stratégie",
une stratégie philosophique,
méthodologique,
mais qui peut également
devenir politique.
Où est-ce qu'on se situe
par rapport à cette question ?
La crise écologique,
le traitement des animaux
à travers l'industrie animale,
est-ce que ça contraint
le philosophe à devenir militant ?
Comment on se distribue soi-même
dans ces différentes fonctions,
de citoyen, de chercheur,
de philosophe ?
-Moi, je n'aime pas trop
le mot "militant".
Le philosophe doute,
le philosophe est là
pour mettre de la perplexité
sur le monde
et son rapport au monde,
tout en étant engagé,
est un engagement indirect,
si j'ose dire.
La valeur ajoutée
du travail philosophique
n'est pas d'aller défiler
avec des pancartes
mais elle est de prendre du recul
et elle est aussi de penser
contre soi-même,
en particulier quand on est
philosophe politique.
On peut être pur dans sa cuisine
mais, dès lors qu'il s'agit
de penser des normes
pouvant être universalisables
ou instituer le bien commun,
toujours à définir et à redéfinir,
dans une démocratie qui,
par définition,
l'institue de manière
non définitive,
il faut aussi tenir compte
des personnes
qui pensent différemment
et des intérêts divergents.
Ou alors,
on abandonne la démocratie,
ce qui, pour moi et pour vous,
est impossible
et surtout,
pas souhaitable.
Du coup, il y a là à essayer
de construire des accords
sur fond de nos désaccords
et néanmoins, il faut bien avoir
un certain courage politique
pour dire qu'il y a certaines choses
qu'on ne va plus faire.
C'est comme ça que des progrès
sont advenus.
Il y a eu abolition
de la peine de mort en 81
parce qu'on avait jugé
que la peine de mort
était mauvaise,
contreproductive, ne permettait pas
de baisser la criminalité, etc.
Je ne reprendrai pas les arguments
de Badinter,
dont le discours à l'Assemblée
est formidable.
Mais là, il y a
un courage politique à avoir,
donc il s'agit de tracer...
De voir quelles pratiques peuvent
être aujourd'hui abolies
car elles ne sont plus soutenues
par la population,
elles sont nuisibles à l'écologie,
à la vie sociale, etc.,
comme l'élevage industriel,
comme aussi beaucoup de pratiques
mutilantes pour les animaux,
il peut y avoir même des élevages
assez industriels
sans les mutilations des cochons,
sans la castration à vif, etc.,
il y a des pays qui le font,
et quelles pratiques,
sans être abolies tout de suite,
peuvent être modifiées,
avec des aménagements.
Dans le "Manifeste animaliste",
troisième partie,
je vais dresser une liste
des propositions
qu'on pouvait faire
et surtout,
des moyens de le faire.
On ne peut pas supprimer
certains métiers,
par exemple,
de dresseur de fauves
dans les cirques
avec animaux sauvages,
et les mettre au chômage
du jour au lendemain.
Il y a l'idée d'une reconversion,
le respect de l'identité
de ces personnes,
qui s'est construite
dans ces métiers.
Donc le philosophe, c'est quand même
quelqu'un qui aime la complexité,
ou en tout cas,
qui doit l'assumer.
Et donc, quand il s'agit
de donner quelques idées,
quelques guidelines,
quelques principes
qui pourraient permettre d'instituer
le bien commun sur un sujet,
non seulement il est bon
qu'il connaisse le terrain
et les difficultés rencontrées,
mais il est bon aussi,
et surtout, il est nécessaire
qu'il pense aussi contre lui-même
pour essayer de trouver
quelque chose de valide
de manière, on va dire,
pas universelle
mais quand même, générale.
Et ça, c'est ça...
Alors que le militant,
les militants...
J'ai rencontré plusieurs militants,
animalistes, écologistes,
ou aussi, quand je travaillais
avec des associations de protection
des malades Alzheimer,
ils ont des niches.
L'animaliste ne s'intéressera pas
tellement aux malades d'Alzheimer,
et vice-versa.
Le philosophe,
il travaille,
et souvent aussi
contre lui-même.
Donc, je crois
que c'est pour ça que le rapport
du philosophe au politique
et même au militant ou à la cité,
comme disait Lévi-Strauss,
il est toujours en tension.
Une tension
qui est intéressante,
mais il n'y a jamais de confusion.
Et en plus,
il n'y a rien
de plus antiphilosophique
que l'idéologie.
-Certes.
En en même temps,
la radicalité fait bouger
les lignes politiques.
-Oui, chez les militants.
C'est clair qu'on peut...
On peut parfois être agacé
par des militants.
Mais si on se rappelle
de ce que disait Serge Moscovici,
qui a travaillé
sur les minorités actives,
il distinguait les minorités
des minorités actives,
qui ont un impact par le fait
que celles-ci, souvent,
étaient en rupture
avec les normes,
et il le faisait de manière
très cohérente mais parfois,
assez, disons musclée.
Sans violence, mais disons,
de manière...
Ils n'hésitaient pas
à afficher leur hétérodoxie,
comme il disait élégamment,
et que c'est ça
qui faisait bouger les lignes.
Et effectivement, souvent,
les changements sociaux
ne s'opèrent pas
par les arguments,
sinon, ça se saurait,
mais par, justement,
ces mouvements
et au niveau inconscient.
Il est vrai
que depuis quelques années,
on peut toujours critiquer
certaines associations
de protection animale, L214,
mais n'empêche que...
Moi, je les critique pas,
je les aime beaucoup,
mais je trouve que
ce qu'ils ont réussi à faire,
c'est que même si tout le monde
n'a pas vocation
à devenir végan,
beaucoup s'interrogent aujourd'hui
sur la provenance de la viande
et que même ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord avec ces militants
sont amenés,
voire contraints
à se poser cette question.
Et ça, je crois
que c'est important.
De toute façon, il n'y a pas
de changements sociaux
sans une certaine turbulence,
et je crois que la démocratie,
n'en déplaise à ceux qui aiment
beaucoup l'ordre,
et à un moment, il faut de l'ordre
quand on institue des lois,
la démocratie est toujours
un peu sauvage
puisqu'elle redéfinit
le bien commun,
avec des enjeux nouveaux,
et donc, du coup,
après, il s'agit d'encadrer
la conflictualité.
Non pas s'y opposer,
mais pas non plus confondre
conflictualité et violence,
violence verbale, physique,
ni tyrannie du bien.
La démocratie suppose
tellement de maturité,
tellement de qualités,
pas seulement intellectuelles
mais de capacité à vivre ensemble,
dans cette conflictualité.
Ca demande tellement,
et c'est vrai que notre époque
aime bien les clivages,
les réflexes identitaires.
La philosophie, comme la démocratie,
qui se ressemblent tant,
"qui sont nées au même endroit",
disait Castoriadis,
supposent justement
cette ouverture, de ne pas avoir
ces réflexes identitaires,
et ça, je crois que c'est peut-être
la chose du monde
la moins bien partagée
aujourd'hui.
-Justement, quel est le rôle,
selon vous,
du philosophe dans la cité ?
Vous y avez un peu répondu,
mais on a coutume de dire,
dans l'histoire
de la philosophie,
qu'il a tantôt été roi,
tantôt ermite en dehors de la cité,
parfois conseiller du prince.
Vous le verriez où
dans la mêlée démocratique ?
-Alors, aucun de ces rôles,
même s'il les embrasse parfois.
Mais je dirais
que le philosophe,
sa valeur ajoutée,
c'est cette instabilité,
j'allais dire,
ou plutôt le fait qu'il n'est pas
identifié à cette fonction-là,
de conseiller du prince ou de roi.
D'ailleurs, ça se passe
en général très mal
quand il est conseiller du prince.
Platon a été vendu
comme esclave.
Et puis, d'ermite...
Oui. C'est-à-dire que la distance
du philosophe, son détachement
se fait pour un engagement,
et son engagement est inséparable
d'un certain détachement,
donc il y a un engagement indirect.
Mais quand même, le philosophe,
je crois, il est là pour, peut-être,
non seulement donner
un esprit critique aux gens,
des outils pour mieux penser
le monde,
mais je dirais qu'aujourd'hui,
où le lien entre théorie et pratique
a été brisé,
notamment après la fin
des grandes idéologies,
des grandes utopies politiques,
je crois qu'il est important
qu'au lieu de voir de manière
surplombante les choses
et de donner des leçons de morale,
il s'agit peut-être
d'accompagner,
d'avoir un regard sensible
sur ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
et d'être capable d'accompagner
des mouvements qui existent
en mettant des liens
entre les vivants et les morts,
le passé et le présent,
sans penser qu'on va tout changer
du jour au lendemain
mais en essayant de voir
dans le passé
ceux qui peuvent nous éclairer,
philosophes ou autres,
et en voyant aussi
ce qui change,
où sont les défis,
et d'accompagner un mouvement,
justement,
en lui donnant une cohérence.
Donc moi,
je crois que c'est pour ça
que c'est une rationalité
sensible.
Il s'agit de parler au monde
et pas seulement sur lui.
Et ça, c'est peut-être quelque chose
qui demande de l'empathie.
Et donc, une philosophie
de professeur ne suffit pas.
Moi, plus va, et sans doute
est-ce parce que je vieillis,
plus je me rends compte
que mon expérience,
si petite soit-elle,
inspire beaucoup de mes thèmes
et sans doute
explique une certaine attention
au vivant, à la vulnérabilité,
mais aussi explique
l'acceptation d'un vertige
au coeur de mes plus grandes
convictions,
qui les renverse.
-Vous êtes toujours
en dialogue avec vous-même,
comme le veut la définition
platonicienne de la pensée ?
-Peut-être parfois
un peu contre moi-même.
-Vous êtes une démocratie
à vous toute seule.
-Je ne sais pas !
-La conflictualité interne...
-Ricoeur répond à ces questions
dans "Soi-même comme un autre".
Il y a une dialectique
entre soi et soi,
entre soi-idem, les repères qu'on a
et qui souvent volent en éclats
à l'occasion de crises personnelles
et l'ipse, c'est-à-dire
ce qu'on est soi-même
mais qu'on définit
à un autre niveau, et souvent
de manière fragile,
forte et fragile à la fois,
qui se définit
par ce en quoi on croit,
l'attestation, dont il rappelle
le lien en allemand,
"Bezeugung" avec "Zeugnis",
"témoignage"
et "Bezeugung", "conviction".
Et puis, il y a la dialectique
entre moi et autrui.
Les grandes souffrances viennent
quand même des autres.
Les remises en question
les plus dures
viennent quand même des autres.
De soi, mais aussi des autres.
Et puis, les normes.
Il y a toujours une tension
entre l'exigence
ou le rêve de vie bonne
et puis, la nécessité
de vivre en société
et l'obéissance aux normes.
Donc, il y a quand même
ces trois tensions,
ça fait beaucoup
pour une seule personne,
pour chacun d'entre nous,
ce qui fait que la vie
est sans cesse une reconstruction.
-Exercice difficile :
pouvez-vous définir
la grande question philosophique
d'aujourd'hui ?
-Eh bien, justement,
je dirais que c'est le progrès,
parce que c'est une notion
qui ne séduit pas grand monde
aujourd'hui,
et on comprend pourquoi.
Il y a plein de phénomènes
de régression,
tant au niveau social,
politique,
au niveau des moeurs
dans certains pays,
et puis aussi, évidemment,
les technologies,
souvent, nous échappent,
ont des conséquences, etc.,
et néanmoins,
je ne veux pas l'abandonner.
Même au singulier.
Parce que des progrès, il y en a,
mais le progrès...
Je dirais, comme Adorno,
que le progrès commence
là où il se termine.
Il faut en finir avec un crédo
qui identifiait le progrès
à la croissance illimitée,
ça, c'est terminé.
Mais le progrès,
je crois, justement,
qu'au coeur même
d'une conscience tragique,
d'une conscience aiguë
de la possibilité
de notre impossibilité,
de l'effondrement,
pas seulement liée
au réchauffement climatique,
qui ne souligne pas seulement
notre vulnérabilité
mais celle, aussi,
de notre civilisation,
au coeur même de ce qui est
presque un désespoir,
il y a peut-être, en tout cas...
Oui, il y a
la possibilité de penser
un âge du vivant,
ou en tout cas des signes
avant-coureurs d'un âge
qui pourrait réenclencher
un processus civilisationnel
et qui s'appuierait sur, justement,
la prise en compte
de notre finitude,
de notre vulnérabilité
par une révolution anthropologique
liée à un projet politique
où on habite la Terre autrement,
où on en finit avec cette prédation
et cette domination.
Mais je crois qu'on peut,
et peut-être, on doit maintenir
la notion de progrès.
-Merci beaucoup,
Corine Pelluchon.
-Merci.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
...